looking to help secure sensitive data
and prevent fraud with recaptcha
Enterprise and assured workloads
customers in regulated Industries can
protect their applications that run on
Google cloud from fraudulent activity
and abuse
hi I'm Chloe and in this video I'll be
walking you through how public sector
agencies can help protect the privacy
and sensitive data of their constituents
using recaptcha Enterprise for fraud
detection and authentication Services
while securing the underlying regulated
infrastructure using assured workloads
[Music]
thank you
today many public sector entities
provide services to their constituents
and in doing so they frequently need to
create accounts and logins to access
their sensitive personal information
unfortunately these public sector
services are often the target of Bad
actors who use various methods to take
over accounts running automated attacks
using passwords exposed in data leaks or
exploiting security misconfigurations a
account takeovers are typically followed
by the attacker transferring money
buying gift cards making purchases with
the compromised users account or
accessing more of the user's information
for leverage in a progressive attack
knowing when a user is impacted by a
data leak is critical information as
they may have reused their password on
other websites and made themselves
vulnerable to account takeovers but how
can app owners and users get insight
into these potential risks public sector
entities use assured workloads to help
protect the sensitive data they store
and process on Google Cloud as short
workloads enforces security controls and
guard rails needed to protect
infrastructure while maintaining
compliance standards but securing the
underlying infrastructure does not
provide complete protections for
constituents data or accounts which is
why these entities combine assured
workloads with free captcha Enterprise
while many anti-fraud and abuse
Solutions exist they typically only have
visibility at the request level and not
the client level this allows threats to
masquerade as valid clients putting
users data at risk
these Solutions are also often focused
on single use cases such as credit card
fraud and won't necessarily help when it
comes to issues such as identifying and
stopping account takeovers or being able
to provide insights into whether
constituents were impacted by data leaks
with assured workloads and recaptcha
Enterprise you can easily identify
privacy and security issues without
adding user friction this combined
solution includes guard rails and
security control monitoring to reduce
misconfigurations and provides fraud and
Bot protection actions can be taken
based on security risk and compliance
requirements for example the solution
may require constituents to use
two-factor or email authentication to
protect their data when an elevated risk
is detected
let's quickly show you a demo of how to
set this up for yourself
when a user logs in with an email and
password recaptcha Enterprise will
return you a score for that user between
zero and one here in this example we see
a 0.9 this means this is a human let's
take a look at how this works alongside
account Defender
when the user returns we see a similar
score of 0.9 as well as a label profile
match this means that the same user has
returned
now let's see an example where someone
else attempts to log in on behalf of a
user
when we check the visitor we can see a
new score of 0.6
an account Defender has identified that
there is suspicious login activity
and the recommendation is to request
two-factor identification for this user
with password Leak Detection public
sector entities can audit user accounts
against Google's 5 billion plus database
of compromise credentials to ensure that
users login information has not been
leaked or breached this can guide
immediate action to protect users data
without them even being aware an
incident involving their password has
occurred as you can see in this example
when leaked credentials are used
recaptcha performs a check against our
database it lets us know that the
password for this username has been
previously leaked which means as
developers we can prompt our users to
reset their password and two-factor
authenticate them to ensure it is in
fact the correct user making a login
attempt our annotations API is also
available to use to let us know how the
assessment is gone for example was this
a legitimate user versus suspicious
login and more
this public sector solution is helping
agencies and local governments across
the U.S and World protect their
constituents while maintaining the
highest levels of compliance and
security without compromise as we
continue this series we will see other
regulated Solutions designed to increase
protection reduce security
misconfigurations and Empower public
sector entities to provide highly secure
online services to the public thanks for
tuning in for more information check out
our documentation or take a look at the
links provided in the description below
for more info on how you can use assured
workloads to protect sensitive data
privacy in your applications
please
[Music]